- This video is brought
to you by Scentbird.
(upbeat music)
What's up guys, Michael here
to talk about a group of individuals
responsible for making sure
that society is just and fair.
- You have my sword.
(triumphant music)
- And you have my bow.
- And my axe.
- [Michael] No, not those guys.
We're talking about the Supreme Court,
one of the three co-equal
branches of government.
It was created to provide checks
and balances on the others.
But as the recent leak of
the current court's decision
regarding Roe v. Wade hit the news,
you might have wondered,
wasn't this already decided?
If not, are all of our
laws subject to change?
And how did nine unelected folks
end up with our fates
in their very old hands?
Let's find out
in this Wisecrack Edition
on the Supreme Court.
What went wrong?
- But before we get into it,
(upbeat music)
I wanna tell you about this
video sponsor, Scentbird.
Scentbird is a fragrance
subscription service
that helps you discover
your personal style
and grow your fragrance collection.
Every month, you receive a 30-day supply
of your new set of your choice.
This month, I tried
Maison 21G Sage Supreme
and I love the fresh green woody notes.
It reminds me of summers
growing up in Tennessee
when I would go see
movies with my friends,
or just hang out with my family.
I also tried the scent Book by Commodity,
which has notes of bergamot,
eucalyptus, and sandalwood.
Like its name suggests,
this scent really feels like
curling up with a good book.
Scentbird's wide selection
includes both luxury brands
and cool indie brands like Gucci,
Confessions of a Rebel,
Heretic And Versace.
If you're not sure where to start,
Scentbird can point you
in the right direction
with help from a handy online quiz.
Scentbird takes the risk
out of investing in a whole
pot of fragrance right away,
which can be a pretty pricey mistake
if you wind up regretting your choice.
Instead, you can get a
month-long test drive,
or if you like to mix up your scent
with your mood or with the seasons,
Scentbird, it is a great way
to build a library of
fragrances for every collection.
Scentbird subscriptions
are just $17 a month,
and if you're in the US or Canada,
and wanna get 55% off your
first month of Scentbird,
click the link below
or go to scentbird.com
and enter code WISECRACK55 at checkout.
Thanks again to Scentbird
for partnering with us on this video,
and don't miss the link
in the description.
And now, back to the show.
- [Michael] Let's start
in the 18th century.
When the drafters of the constitution
called for the creation
of the Supreme Court
as a means of balancing out
the power of the president and Congress,
the document establishes
three important things about the court.
First, it gives it ultimate judicial power
while allowing Congress
to establish other lower
courts as it saw fit.
Side note, it doesn't actually
explicitly say what judicial power means.
Basically, leaving Congress
to eat, pray, and love
on that minor issue.
Secondly, it states that
judges on these courts
shall hold their office
during good behavior.
This has been interpreted to mean
that Supreme Court justices
are appointed for life
and don't have to leave unless they croak,
retire of Florida,
or do something shifty
like treason or bribery.
Lastly, it says that judges pay
can't be decreased while
they're on the bench
to ensure they aren't
being swayed by politicians
who could retaliate
against court decisions
by docking their pay.
And that's essentially
what the founders had to say about it.
It was up to Congress
to use this blueprint
and figure out what the heck
a Supreme Court was anyway.
Now, believe it or not,
the court was intended
to be an apolitical body,
interpreting the law through
the frame of the constitution
and not any partisan set of beliefs.
Seriously, that's not a bit.
That's really what it was supposed to be.
The constitution was also really
vague on details regarding
the establishment of federal
courts outside of SCOTUS.
This may have been on purpose.
As law professors, Richard W. Garnett
and David A. Strauss put it,
"To some people in the
United States at that time,
the federal government
seemed almost like a foreign government.
Those people's main loyalty
was to their states."
As a result, a network of federal courts
with elite judges
handpicked by the president,
legislating in far-flung states,
"Amounted to allowing the
foreign federal government
to get its tentacles into
every corner of the nation."
So, the issue was delicate.
On the one hand, who can
blame people for being worried
that a bunch of hoity-toity elites
with no ties to their communities
can make decisions for them.
On the other hand, some of the framers
were concerned that leaving
too much power to state courts
meant that hostile states
could undermine the laws of the land.
Thus, Congress determined
that state courts
could get a fairly wide birth
in figuring out local laws for themselves.
At the same time, they
acknowledged that the Supreme Court
established the supreme laws of the land
and would have the power to intervene
if a state court made an
unconstitutional ruling.
Now, none of this would be the final say
on what SCOTUS became because,
and I cannot stress this enough,
very little about the Supreme Court
is in our actual constitution.
And early Congress had
a lot to figure out,
like the makeup of the court,
including the number
of justices and so on.
Consequently, the court's
responsibilities and jurisdictions
have changed multiple
times since its inception.
So, what has been the function
of the Supreme Court in America
and how has that function changed.
And has the institution over
time become too powerful?
To figure that out,
let's look at one of the most
pivotal moments for the court,
which occurred in its
tentative early days.
A paradigm-changing Supreme
Court decision was reached
under chief justice, John Marshall,
who had been appointed
during some characteristically
petty theatrics
between outgoing president, John Adams,
and his nemesis, Thomas Jefferson.
After Jefferson defeated Adams,
the lame duck, present as Congress,
passed the Judiciary Act of 1801,
which expanded the number of
federal courts and judges.
Adams immediately used this new law
to appoint a bunch of midnight judges,
one surprisingly favored him.
But there wasn't enough
time to formally carry out
all these appointments
before Adam left office.
Those appointees not
officially commissioned,
were in Jefferson's eyes,
rendered null and void.
One snob appointee
was would-be DC Justice of
the Peace William Marbury.
He took the issue to
Marshall Supreme Court,
which found that indeed,
Marbury had a right to the job.
But Marshall wasn't sure if it was really
the Supreme Court's place
to make this ruling.
To TLDR This legalese,
the court decided that for the most part,
it did not have original jurisdiction,
meaning it couldn't rule on
a case for the first time,
but it did have appellate jurisdiction.
That is the authority to
rule on a case on appeal.
So, while Marbury was correct
about his right to the job,
SCOTUS did not have
jurisdiction to make that call,
at least not until it
reached the appeal stage.
Now, it might sound like the Supreme Court
had ruled to limit its power,
but what it really did was establish
the incredibly important
concept of judicial review,
the power of the court
to look at decisions
made by the other branches
of the government and other courts
and determine whether or
not they are constitutional.
Their ruling made it official
that the constitution
wasn't just a set of guidelines,
but was actually the
ultimate law of the land.
And it was up to the Supreme
Court to decide what it meant
and if daddy government
was using it right.
This seems to be in line
with what several of the framers believed,
including Alexander
Hamilton and James Madison.
In theory, this all means
that the court is nonpartisan
and exists solely to make sure
everyone's constitutional
rights are granted.
That sounds great and non-controversial.
But when you tie your decision-making
to an unchanging document,
you set yourself up to be the
voice of a certain status quo,
which is pretty much
what SCOTUS has been
since it's early days.
What's more, as scholars,
Lawrence Baum and Neal Devins,
arguing their study of outside influence
over the court's decisions,
the Supreme Court is disincentivized
from making bold rulings
that might be controversial,
specifically because it
doesn't have any ability
to actually carry out its own decisions.
There's no Supreme Court police force,
except for the buff ghost
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
- So, today, we're gonna be working
all the major muscle groups to the bottom,
that the abs, gams, tuchus,
chicken wings
(chicken clucks)
and critical thinking.
(bell dings)
- And there's no team of
supervising bureaucrats
to ensure that these rulings
are actually enacted.
Thus, the fear of backlash
against an unpopular opinion
has always loomed large.
As the researchers explain,
this can often lead to justices
making narrower rulings
in order to avoid too much controversy.
The result has been that the court
is a relatively conservative body,
not in a sense of
Republican versus Democrat,
but in terms of change versus status quo.
As Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor
writes for "The New Yorker",
"As the branch of government
that is least accountable
to the American public,
the Supreme Court is tended,
for most of its history,
toward a fundamental conservatism,
siding with tradition
over more expansive
visions of human rights."
This makes sense, because again,
they're applying an
increasingly old document
to any given contemporary scenario.
This was certainly the case
when it came to slavery,
which was deemed a question
best left to the states.
In 1857, when the court
ruled that enslaved people
were property, rather than citizens,
the majority of judges were slave owners.
Their take wasn't an aberration.
While slavery isn't explicitly
mentioned in the constitution,
it did specifically protect
the importing of slaves up until 1808.
And the Supreme Court
openly perpetuated the idea
of enslaved people as protective property,
even striking down a Pennsylvania law
that banned using violence
to collect escaped slaves.
As Erwin Chemerinsky writes in his book,
"The Case Against the Supreme Court",
"At every opportunity until the Civil War,
the Supreme Court acted
to protect the rights of slave owners
and denied all rights to
those who were enslaved."
That's 70 years of going
to bat for guys like this.
- He is a rambunctious sword, ain't he?
- You might be thinking,
that was a long time ago.
Things are way better now.
And yes, the court no
longer sanctioned slavery,
but it did take a whole
Civil War to get there.
And obviously, ending
slavery didn't end racism.
And Chemerinsky notes that an
important part of the story
is that the court did nothing
to advance racial equality
for almost 90 years after the Civil War,
and instead, used its power and influence
to limit the protections of
the post-Civil War amendments.
A prime example of this was the separate
but equal decision
under Plessy v. Ferguson
that facilitated segregation
to devastating effects
on the black community.
And the court siding with say,
plantation owners over enslaved people,
wasn't a historical aberration.
It's illustrative of a larger tendency.
In cases where business
or corporate interests clash
with those of the common man,
the court has historically
cited with those empowered.
This was illustrated acutely
during the Gilded Age.
From about 1890 to the 1930s,
the court embraced the
laissez-faire social Darwinism
that dominated political
thought at the time.
They declared freedom of contract,
the freedom to independently negotiate
your own business contract,
a constitutional right,
which allowed them to
strike down tons of laws
that would've protected workers
(brick falling)
and consumers
from big corporations.
(cartoon screaming)
The thinking was, if you were an employer
and your state passed a minimum wage law,
that was an infringement
(scissor snipping)
on your right to set your
own employment terms.
They struck down over
200 federal state
(punching sound effect)
and local economic regulations
to protect the sacred right
of powerful corporations.
The court also took huge
steps to limit federal power
to protect the most vulnerable.
For example, they decided
that a federal ban
(horn blaring)
on interstate shipment of goods
produced by child labor
was unconstitutional
because that should be
left up to the states.
At the time, states that
wanted to ban child labor
risked losing their
competitive business advantages
to states that engaged in it.
Economic pressure, those kept
child labor alive and well.
And the country saw millions of children
working in deadly conditions for decades.
Now, they just have to go to
school for deadly conditions.
We're not gonna put that in the video,
But it's (beep) and it's
dark, and it's true.
So, you know what? I dare you, editor.
Put it in there. Speak truth to power.
Note that just a decade earlier,
the court had ruled
that interstate shipment
of lottery tickets
could be banned
(error sound effect)
by the federal government,
but hey, protecting the nation
from out-of-state lottery tickets,
but not from child labor
seems totally normal
and reasonable.
Again, what we're seeing
in this time period
is a general reluctance to
protect vulnerable people
from government or corporate power.
It's easy now to look back
and lament the way the
Supreme court functioned
pre-Civil war or in the Gilded Age,
but it's worth more closely examining
what happened under the court
in its more progressive errors of history.
Take Chief Justice Earl Warren's court,
often considered the last one
to truly represent the
interest of the common man.
Earlier courts weren't known
for expanding civil rights and liberties,
but Warren was openly
committed to social justice.
Once more, he was likable and persuasive,
which led to even some of
the most controversial cases
that came across SCOTUS' desk,
reaching unanimous or
near unanimous decisions
from the justices,
which is basically unheard of
today for such divisive cases.
Brown v. Board of Education,
the landmark decision, which
reversed to the separate,
but equal doctrine, was
decided unanimously.
This is directly because
of Warren's influence.
According to another
Justice's autobiography,
had the Supreme Court ruled in 1952
when the case was initially argued
and before Warren joined the court,
there would've been a 5-4
vote to uphold segregation.
What in the actual (beep)
Then there was Gideon v. Wainwright,
which found that everyone has the right
to legal counsel in a criminal case.
And Loving v. Virginia,
which ruled that laws
banning interracial marriage
were unconstitutional.
These decisions helped create
a constitutional precedent
that allowed Congress
to pass other important
pieces of legislation
like the Civil Rights Act of 1964
and the Voting Rights Act of 1965.
But not everyone was
happy with this progress,
especially the
definitely-not-a-crook Richard Nixon.
Nixon maintained a 30-year
beef with Earl Warren,
who had refused to endorse him
earlier in his political career.
So, when Nixon became president,
he wanted to tear down
everything that Warren had built.
And due to some squabbling
that foreshadowed
Barack Obama's nomination of
Merrick Garland being squashed,
Nixon was able to fill four seats
over the course of his short presidency.
His goal he said, was to a
point strict constructionists.
These guys would be,
"Interpreting the law, not making the law.
They would see themselves as
caretakers of the constitution
and servants of the people,
not super-legislators with a free hand
to impose their political
and social viewpoints."
At first glance, this sounds
relatively apolitical,
but it was actually the first glimmer
of an important philosophy
that would change the way
the Supreme Court functioned.
And Nixon's strict constructionist judges
were expected to roll back
some of the Warren Court's
broad constructionist decisions
to expand human rights.
That's why things like
abortion or same sex marriage
aren't ruled expressly
legal by the Supreme Court,
but instead, use constitutional reasoning
like the equal protection
clause and the right to privacy.
This is also what makes any rights
not expressly delineated in
the constitution so tenuous,
even if they're popular with citizens.
And while Nixon's appointee,
Chief justice Burger,
did not roll back the
Warren Court's decisions
on mass as expected,
his appointment cemented an
ideological shift in the court.
It went from expanding civil liberties
to seeing such expansions of rights
as outside of the purview
of the constitution.
Like it's earlier iterations,
this new court regularly
ruled in favor of corporate
and institutional interest
against regular citizens.
Today, the Supreme Court
has several justices
who follow strict constructionism,
specifically what is called textualism,
which holds that the constitution
should be interpreted the
way your average person
in 1787 would've interpreted it.
How does that account for say,
the rise of global capitalism
or the invention of the AK-47
or the rise of the internet
you might be wondering?
It doesn't really.
But surely, you must be wondering
what to make of those few
exciting Supreme Court cases
you learned about in high school,
which takes us back to the Warren Court,
because it evokes a more romantic
vision of the institution.
And yet even some of its
most groundbreaking decisions
look mealy-mouthed in retrospect
Take Brown v. Board,
which ended legal government
mandated segregation.
Surely, we're not going to
critique this ruling, right?
Well, in reality,
while the Warren Court struck
down lots of individual cases
brought to them about
segregation in courtrooms,
on buses, on golf courses,
and restaurants, and so on,
they never wrote an opinion
that said state governments
actually had to do anything
to actively end segregation
or prevent it from happening.
Quite the opposite, in fact.
As Robert L. Carter
wrote in the "Michigan
Law Review" in 1968,
"The court ruled that a state
is under no affirmative obligation
to enact anti-discrimination legislation
and that such laws may be repealed;
but the court added the
precautionary caveat
that if in the process of repeal
the state tips the political balance
in favor of racial discrimination,
it violates the 14th Amendment."
So, a state not only
didn't have to put any laws
in place to end discrimination,
but they also were within their rights
to repeal anti-discrimination legislation,
as long as they didn't do an oopsie
and tip the scales towards
intentional discrimination,
which is totally a very easy
and objective thing to
measure and prevent.
Thus, I'm sure you'll be shocked to hear
that virtually no school desegregation
actually happened for years after Brown.
It wasn't until the
Civil Rights Act of 1964
that any meaningful progress
was made in desegregation,
and that was limited mostly
to cities in the south.
In San Antonio Independent
School District v. Rodriguez,
SCOTUS even went so far as to rule
that inequalities in school
funding aren't illegal
because get this,
the right to equal education
isn't in the constitution.
That's right.
SCOTUS ruled that it's fine for schools
to be both separate and unequal
as long as the segregation isn't
mandated by the government.
And in the 50 years since Brown,
the Supreme Court has
made America's segregation
and inequality problems even worse.
Like the 1991 decision
in which the Oklahoma City School Board
ceased busing black
students to white schools
as a desegregation effort
because schools had
become less segregated.
And surprisingly,
(error sound effect)
when the busing ended,
the schools became segregated again.
And while there's plenty
wrong with busing,
SCOTUS-ruled schools
don't have to be equal
in terms of funding,
and you can probably guess
(coins clinks)
whose schools weren't being funded.
Still, the court ruled that
federal acts like busing
were only meant as a temporary measure
to remedy past discrimination.
So, because black students
have been given their rights
for the past 13 years,
the Supreme Court assumed
that the racial problem at
the root had been fixed.
What this really meant was that schools
stopped being segregated by law,
but remained effectively
segregated by where people lived.
And because it was fine
for schools to be unequal,
black and Latino
(cartoon screaming)
students suffered.
Overall, if you look at the Supreme Court
over the past 50 years,
you can see how a general
passivity towards granting rights
has implicitly stripped
many of those rights
away from many Americans.
Take the time in 2011
when a class action lawsuit
against Walmart was filed
on behalf of 1.5 million women,
arguing that they were paid less than
and had to wait longer
for promotions than men.
Institutionally, there
was no application process
for management and
employees were handpicked.
Unsurprisingly, this resulted
in pay raises and promotions
being disproportionately given to men.
And while on three occasions,
the US Court of Appeals
for the Ninth Circuit
upheld that these women should
be certified as a class,
SCOTUS ruled that there were just
too many of them
(error sound effect)
to have nothing common to
justify a class action suit.
If they wanted to come after Walmart,
they should do it individually instead.
As Adam Cohen points out in
his book, "Supreme Injustice",
the whole point of a class action lawsuit
is that individuals can
collectively share claims
and show ongoing patterns of wrongdoing
without forking out their
life savings for a lawyer.
It is nearly impossible
for one person to show
that they have individually
been discriminated against.
Whereas a large representative
group demonstrates a pattern.
What appears to be a neutral decision
ends up being a huge loss
for average Walmart workers
and a huge win for a massive corporation.
According to studies,
the current Roberts Court
has been the most business-friendly
in nearly a century,
and it's not due to party politics.
Liberal and conservative judges alike
seem to be able to agree
on corporate rights.
Meanwhile, decisions that
pit everyday Americans
against big corporations
and powerful institutions
like the police and prisons
leave us with little recourse
to seek justice for individuals
because in the eyes of the Supreme Court,
the constitution is fair.
Take the decision in
Citizens United v. FEC,
which said that corporations
had the same rights
as individuals to donate
money to political candidates.
In the decades that followed,
wealthy donors and Super PACs
of every political persuasion
have spent over $3
billion to sway elections
toward candidates that will
protect their interests.
While hypothetically,
everyone has the right
to donate to their candidates of choice,
we sadly don't have the right
to the type of money
that PACs have access to.
Thus, the decision inherently
favors one group of people,
the mega wealthy.
This decision isn't too surprising
when you consider that 70%
of Supreme Court Justices
in the past 50 years have
been Ivy League graduates.
As sociologist G. William Domhoff
writes in his book, "Who Rules America?",
"There is both a funneling
and homogenizing effect
from these schools."
This effect, he says,
"Plays out in terms of social networks,
cultural/social capital,
and a feeling of being
part of the in-group."
Scholars Baum and Devins
take this further,
arguing that Supreme Court
Justice's demographics
have material effects on how they rule.
They write, "Supreme Court justices
care more about elite audiences
than they do about the mass public."
As they note, "Like others,
Supreme Court justices want
most to be liked and respected
by people to whom they
are personally close
and people whom they identify.
For the justices,
those people are overwhelmingly
part of elite groups."
And then, as system is set
up for checks and balances
between the three branches of government,
many argue that SCOTUS wields
disproportionate power,
including power over
the will of the people
since they're able to make
wildly unpopular decisions
that don't reflect the majority opinions
of the American public.
There's over 300 million
of us and nine of them.
According to Mickey Edwards,
a former eight-term member of Congress
and chairman of the House
Republican Policy Committee,
the Supreme Court, "Is theoretically
and constitutionally
separate and independent.
But in reality, the
separateness is a bit fuzzy.
That's because even in this
age of hyperpartisanship,
there is at least one important area
in which Democrats and
Republicans think alike:
both parties view the federal courts,
and especially the Supreme Court
as a defacto branch of the legislature."
In other words, while
everyone may talk a big game
about the political neutrality
of the Supreme Court,
politicians of every stripe
have come to understand that in reality,
whichever party appoints the most justices
wields the most power,
particularly in a Congress
too divided to do much of anything.
Does this sound undemocratic?
Well, that may have
been the original point
At the New York Ratifying
Convention for the constitution,
Hamilton himself said that,
"There are few positions,
more demonstrable
than that there should
be, in every Republic,
some permanent body to
correct the prejudices,
check the intemperate passions,
and regulate the fluctuations
of a popular assembly."
This is basically fancy colonial talk
for a rather chilling argument,
that we need special appointed people
to protect us from our literal democracy.
On side note, classic
Greek philosopher, Plato,
would largely agree on this.
(bell dings)
Or as Chemerinsky puts it,
"The primary reason for
having a Supreme Court then
is to enforce the constitution
against the will of the majority."
This seems true in the
expected decision ruling
against Roe V. Wade,
which 64% of the country
wants to see upheld.
You may be thinking, well,
then we should change the constitution.
But this was by design,
made very, very, very difficult to do.
So, in a lot of ways,
we're all still operating by a playbook
written by slave owners in the late 1700s.
As Chemerinsky adds,
"Why should a society generally
committed to majority rule
choose to be governed by a document
that is very difficult to change?"
And we've only grazed
the tip of the iceberg.
If you dig deeper, you'll
find a history of the court
supporting things like eugenics,
Japanese internment camps,
severely limiting free speech
in times of war, and so on.
So, is the Supreme Court beyond fixing?
There are senators and representatives
who have proposed changes
such as expanding the court,
imposing term limits,
and other measures to
curb the massive power
currently afforded to every
Supreme Court Justice.
Of course, with the
filibuster still in place,
putting any of these changes
in motion is basically impossible.
And all of these measures
seem like insurmountably uphill battles.
But if the court continues
to make unpopular decisions,
maybe it'll finally spur
the kind of backlash
they've been dreading since 1787.
- So, you're telling me there's a chance?
- But what do you guys think?
Are the nine perfect strangers
not so perfect after all?
Or should we give them
more credit for legislating
with less than ideal guidance
from the founding fathers?
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
And don't forget
to check out all our
fun, new Patreon perks.
Bang that subscribe button
like it's your favorite gavel,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)
Specifically, what is called textualism.
Text, textual, textual. Oh my god.
Textualism. It's happening.
Oh, no, it's happening.